throughout the force awakens' one of the
biggest mysteries surrounding Rey was
the identity of her parents van theories
were abundant on the internet and all
manner of names were put forward from
Admiral Ackbar to boss nass to Watteau
the junkyard dealer you know the list as
it turns out surprisingly none of those
are the reality or at least that's what
viewers are led to believe during their
confrontation on Snoke ship in the last
Jedi kylo tells Rey that she already
knows who her parents were there nobody
he says to her kylo adds that they
probably sold her off for drinking money
and are now buried in a pauper's grave
what a great guy whilst this might be
disappointing for some fans
it makes Rey and more mysterious and
interesting character it also gives her
a connection to Darth Vader that kylo
will never have Anakin Skywalker like
ray came from nothing he was a nobody he
was strong with the force and ended up
changing the galaxy of course it was for
the worse Rey on the other hand can save
it we see this motif repeat in the film
ending with a nobody standing in a
similar stance to Luke in a new hope
showing that even the smallest of beings
can make an impact in the universe a
graceful way to show that great things
come from small beginnings throughout
the last Jedi rey envisions a dark place
on the island where she trains with
Master Skywalker Luke fearing that she
will always go to the dark wrestles with
the fact that he could be training
another evil apprentice going against
his wishes Rey visits the cave desperate
to learn of her past in the end she sees
nothing but herself whilst people may
think this would lead her down a darker
path knowing that her parents purposely
abandon her in the end it's actually her
salvation tempted by the dark side ray
learns from the fact that her parents
were wicked and selfish and instead of
joining ren decides to make a difference
in the galaxy to mean something a symbol
of hope for all some would even say she
is a new hope some would even say she is
The Return of the Jedi some would even
say she is attack of the clock that one
doesn't really work I know fueled by the
fact that they abandoned her she had to
travel to the dark side to learn the
truth
and takes us knowledge to realize that
it is not a path she wants to travel
down the hate that flows within her for
her parents in fact causes her to rebel
against their personalities and become a
force for good
I got like rebel and force in that
sentence so hold on me similar to this
kylo Ren feels rejected by his parents
after all he was left with a crazy uncle
Luke who got drunk one night and tried
to cut his head off
he Watts Eli anyway it makes for a nice
similarity between the two that adds a
lot of depth of the last Jedi and makes
it one of the best Star Wars films today
so what did you think of the last Jedi
have you seen it make sure you let me
know do you still believe it was boss
nass like I do thanks for checking out
my video please subscribe my channel as
I do videos like this every week and I
hope to add some insight to things that
you love and care about hope to see you
on the next one take care peace